this is Motorola's Moto 360 smartwatch
let me just cut to the chase
this is the best SmartWatch you can buy
right now why well for starters it's the
only SmartWatch that realizes the
importance of looking good see this is
important
smartphones spend a lot of their time in
our pockets or in bags a SmartWatch is
constantly visible so looking good is
really important and the Moto 360
actually clears that bar not only is it
i catching lee round it's actually made
out of luxurious and suitably watching
materials like stainless steel and
leather the 360s display is a colorful
and responsive touch screen it's not
super awesome in bright sunlight but
let's face it few displays really are
when you're not looking at the display
it automatically dims this gives the 360
a battery life without a day when you
want to recharge the Moto 360 you put it
into the included dock that you can keep
on your nightstand which turns your
watch into a little bedside clock the
watch's onboard microphone lets you use
voice commands with it you wake it up by
saying ok Google and then you can issue
your instructions you can tell it to
send a text you can make an appointment
on your calendar you can have it
navigate you to a destination you get
the general idea
navigate me to Rockefeller Center
now to get your watch to do more than
tell time you have to prepare it by a
bluetooth with an Android smartphone and
that smartphone has to have an app on it
called Android wear
Android wear is the link between your
watch and some of the apps on your
smartphone naturally google apps are the
most compatible I can read a Gmail or
make a calendar appointment straight
from my watch but other apps are more
limited for example I can see on my
watch that a friend commented on one of
my Facebook posts but to actually read
that comment I have to open up Facebook
on my phone in the end the Moto 360
isn't actually looking at other
smartwatches for inspiration it's
looking at this an iPod see the iPod
wasn't the first mp3 player out there
but it was the first mp3 player that
made people care about owning an mp3
player we're still in a bit of a
primordial phase when it comes to smart
watches and this watch hopes to really
be the breakthrough now on the hardware
side it may have done that but some of
the kinks of limitations on the software
side still make this feel less than
something truly revolutionary so what I
said at the beginning of this is still
true this really is the best SmartWatch
you can buy right now unless of course
somebody comes up with like a slam dunk
or something
you